pleased to have here on the show
interestingly enough
um a segment ago uh somebody from los
angeles called in
and said that uh i am uh an inspiration
to all follicly challenged people
and then we went to break saying who's
the exact opposite in los angeles of
being followed to the challenge
he's our our next guest now in his ninth
season as general manager of the rams
organization
out here in los angeles for the brand
spanking new stan canyon for his team to
play in just up the road from us here in
the rich eisen show studio les sneed
back here on the program how are you
doing less
you know what a couple of things yeah
stan canyon that
that's probably that nickname should
definitely stick okay very good uh
you can be you know some of us can be
genetically gifted right
you can you know you can really run fast
you can have
hand-eye coordination and just hit a
baseball a long way but
you can be a gm for nine years and still
not have gray hair so
uh genetically gifted that's half down
good dna from mom but i don't know if
that means anything in life
you could no no less i think it means a
lot when you were saying run fast i
literally thought for a split second
you're referring to me
literally for a split second i think
that's on the record that's not
genetically gifted there
and mike trout seems to be doing
you know better with his genetically
and eye quarters in terms of southern
california people yes i i
i would i would agree with that uh now
let's let's uh start this though a
little bit of the personal
uh you did play for auburn correct you
you did uh how how would les need the
general manager
um evaluate les need the uh the player
right well we the better
word or semantic to use uh instead of
play was i did
practice and i helped
a lot of players who did play and many
of those
went on to have nice careers in the uh
nfl i helped them maybe i looked at this
way i helped them get better so that uh
we can compete and senior year went
you know undefeated but we were on
probation and that's kind of the career
so i think
as a general manager i i think as a
general manager
a less sneed evaluation it would have
never gotten to my desk it would never
exist
now who was your coach was that pat dye
were you there when pat dye was
finishing up there
there's a there's a pat die terry bowden
uh kind of mix there okay an overlap
okay there's an overlap between the dye
terry bowden wow so who are who are some
of your teammates that we would have
that we would know when you were there
uh
so let's go my i'll save my my last year
a guy named uh wayne gandy okay who
actually was drafted by the
l.a rams and but wayne someone uh
very gifted in past protection so
probably
played over a decade at left tackle for
rams
uh probably new orleans pittsburgh
steelers
uh with the team uh frank sanders was a
receiver he played with the cardinals so
interestingly right
wayne and frank went on they probably
had the longer careers
but uh were playing for teams at that
particular time who weren't really
winning so you didn't
they weren't household names uh so
that's what uh you know
but some more that let's call it flare
named steven davis
okay uh but he was a freshman running
back when i was probably
a senior uh so uh he didn't get on the
field when i was there but he did get on
the field later and went to the
so there was a there was a there was a
that's probably how i ended up in the
nfl when i ended up gaining there
yes uh kind of your route there is
because we did have a lot of prospects
like a willie anderson
who went on to play a long time with the
cincinnati uh
bean goals sure we had a lot of first
round first round talent so you did have
a lot of general managers
who did come through auburn again not
necessarily to look at the less needs
of the world but to some of these other
players that went on to have good
careers less need
general manager of the los angeles rams
joining me here
now you probably played the longest tony
richardson do you remember the fullback
of course of course he probably had a
hard knock segment
a great human just a great human another
great an actual and like
as well as a an even better human than
player tony richardson yeah i think
there's a
there's a good story right he was such a
a beast even as a true freshman i think
he was
running scout team as a true freshman
and somewhere in training camp
right uh pat dyer probably looked over
and said okay you're no longer on
scout team you're gonna go over here
with the
real real guys and help us win as a
freshman so
i love it every now and then there's
there's players like that but he did
play a long time as well so
all right you have my mind thinking
though
let's talk about the hearing now uh less
i want the straight like general manager
uh you know inside scoop here do you get
texts from your colleagues after signing
jalen ramsey to
a record-setting contract like that
saying why'd you do that what are you
what gives do you get texts like come on
you get something like that
you know you know you they're uh you get
a a few of those but usually the texts
you get are going to be
from maybe uh maybe closer comrades that
uh it's it's more in joking but uh
if we and maybe it's that time of year
right where you're getting close to
keeping score so
uh you know you don't you don't get any
really serious
but there's a germ of truth even some
jokes like i mean do you when you make a
deal like this no
okay i'm setting when i do this i know
that i'm resetting a market for a lot of
my colleagues
but i don't care because this is my
player and i'm going to do it
uh i think uh you know that that that is
true but i do think
uh in i think most general managers even
probably the majority of
of agents right probably realize when
uh there is a player who definitely has
the chance the potential the
production to reset a market and then
and then there's a others with the
awareness that okay
maybe not a reset uh player but someone
who
deserves to be you know well paid so i
i think the awareness definitely sets in
amongst you know all of us who are in
the nfl ecosystem so
you probably have less of that than uh
than you would think okay and then in
terms of uh the next several years
though
uh the cap maybe being where do things
stand uh on the covet 19 front with the
cap over the next couple of years and
how you're trying to work it into
uh ramsay knowing what your golf
contract is knowing what your donald
contract is
how does that all uh operate for you
right now so i'll probably have a
i'm going to keep it simple and and then
you can go from there
now own cap and then i got about seven
bull bullet points that'll
kind of go overall philosophy right so
cap wise right the only certainty that
we know is
at this point right early in the season
less fans means less revenue that so
there is now
a floor on the cap what the real cap
is is still uncertain
but we definitely mean prepare for that
that certainty that what if it does get
to
175 based on on lost revenue so uh
that that's to be determined i think
end of the day big picture and then we
can get to specifically
uh jalen ramsey right ultimately as a gm
you
you want to you have a vision right to
build something
have this breakthrough uh get i call it
get that playoff
piano off your back that okay can they
win in the playoffs
and then contend how can we do that i
think i think one of the more important
things you can do right is
get the right head coach that can
engineer an environment that earns wins
you got to stabilize the the qb position
uh
and then from there you got to learn to
win and maneuver to contend from there
so uh cap veterans
so here's one thing we do it is our
calculus formula right and let's call it
the 17 the 19 ram since sean's been our
head coach
is it working so uh
do we do we know in the show the the
formula the av
so actual value kind of an analytics
formula i'm not sure
who came up with it but one way to
measure it's an independent way of
measuring
players who play start produce get
awards
so obviously in the in the trade maybe
ufa
free agent signings waiver claims since
17
we're first uh in average uh per
contributor
in that formula so that's where a jaylen
ramsey comes in
but when you take on this
this philosophy and actually start to
execute it
uh and you give up some first rounders
for some known contributors yes
definitely need to like get on base hit
some doubles even some triples in the in
the second through seventh round but
in that same using the av formula
probably since 17
we're seventh in the uh nfl and
cumulative to
av from second through seventh rounders
eliminating
the first round well you're not lying
less that you said you're going to keep
it simple and then get a little bit more
bullet point complicated after that and
in terms of
but so in terms of you know hitting the
doubles and triples
uh in the draft as well as maybe some
undrafted free agents and
and whatnot uh i do want to hit you with
a couple of conventional wisdom
and i know it's you know they call it
that because it's conventional
uh no gurley and running back by
committee
and then uh cooks is gone and wondering
who's gonna be catching passes along
with
cup and woods for your
franchise quarterback let's take it one
at a time their running game is going to
look like what this year
well i think the the running games still
to be determined
and what we do know is we really like
where cam's at and he's ready to roll
even though no off season we have a
very very stable let's call it veteran
uh that stabilized that room in malcolm
round who's
been very successful for us probably had
some of the more
tough yards since 2017
for us uh in that in four-minute
situations right and that's that's when
you're trying to close
out a game and basically everybody in
the stands and everybody on television
knows they're
they're gonna try to run out the clock
and and the running backs getting the
ball
he's been successful there so i think
between those two
mix in uh the henderson when he does get
healthy and primed
and go from from there so at this point
right committee approach
uh and usually uh from there there will
be
either a hot hand or someone who
who uh you know proves it you know what
hand me the ball more
than the next guy so that's still to be
determined but we do like that approach
and then
the passing game what's that going to
look like i think that you know that's i
think shawn's been
at his best when we can distribute the
football i think if you've looked at
i mean if you really analyzed our you
know who gets the ball when they get the
ball
how often they get the ball how many
yards after
they get the ball from our top uh three
receivers whether it's been brandon coax
robert wood
sammy watkins uh cooper cub i mean
we definitely distribute the football to
not only them but the tight end to the
running backs as sean calls them the
five eligibles
uh in that we're going to definitely
need van jefferson to
to step up and he's been doing that in
practice but
as alan iverson has said you know
eloquently yes practice his practice
right
and then so the tight ends is going to
be a bit more of a focus
as well this year i imagine correct i
don't want you to give up too much of
that ghost here in the room
give up uh she didn't give up that but
uh
we do like our our tight ends and i do
know uh sean has in his
dna that you know the ability to to
and and we've done that plenty right
it's sure run both
tight ends and we'll see what we do but
uh
what we the goal for us i think is
whether it's tight ends whether it's
it's it's receivers whether it's running
backs
is be able to run the ball and that
doesn't
necessarily mean the receivers got to
catch the football they gotta they got
to be heinz ward
at times and and actually be an
offensive tackle or full
back or tied in and go back to those
days when
pittsburgh everybody knew they were
going to hand it to 36 but
uh heinz award could block like a tight
end so
that was very effective and then you can
marry that whole
uh run game with the pass game and and
the goal when everybody says marry run
with pass
that means when you line up right and
and this
the the quarterbacks either under center
or taking
you know the snap from the gun you can't
really look down there and go you know
what i think they're going to do this
and then when the play starts and the
whole action of the running backs and
quarterbacks in there
it just looks like it could be runner
pass early
and that's the goal and usually from the
same damn formation too it's so much fun
to watch when sean mcvay is dialing it
up and
and uh a couple more questions left for
you les let's start with your new
defensive coordinator
you know um who is he and what do you
like about him and what's he going to do
uh something in a way that the son of
bum
did uh so well for you over the last
several years
uh so first of all brandon staley right
everybody should get to know brandon
one of the uh one of the the
uh reason sean was very impressed uh
with brandon and it the initial the
let's call
attraction started with with what vic
fangio has done
over his career at many different stops
wherever that was
at and then sean competing against
they can kind of how they have evolved
uh let's call it hey vic back in the
in the harbaugh nfc west days
uh and i was a part of that and it was
some ground and pound going on but now
the nfl is spreading out a little bit
but to see see
vic evolve and and still be
a very formative foe uh in terms of
defensive
football uh so that dna was very
interesting
uh and sean was curious to
to tap into it and then once you meet uh
brandon you certain interview and very
similar
very similar to song probably about
six to eight minutes into an interview
you realize okay wait a minute
uh they're they're like they're rain man
they're
their their high-end physicists are
they're working at spacex putting
rockets in space it just happens to be
you know you know x's and o's versus
whatever apple and microsoft are doing
in their code right they got different
letters football does
x and those and
you know microsoft apple does they do
their own phd i love no i
i love it you're and i'd love being
around guys like that and then in terms
of your job loss i don't know if you
took public health classes at uab or
auburn when you were there
but we we all have to be somewhat more
up to speed on it now
are you quarantining a quarterback how
are you how is uh
coven affecting your gig this fall
well uh we're taking the approach right
now probably uh probably a less extreme
measure maybe
philly if it's true now this is this was
my
teenagers telling me that philly was
signing
josh and keeping him in texas but right
you know they're they're the ones that
get the
let's call it the right the the social
media reports on the hour so they keep
me abreast of the nfl that's how gm's do
it
now i think the nice thing about
what's been going on i think the pa the
nfl
and then everyone involved executing it
from staff coaches players
we're showing that you know there's a
there's an element of discipline
uh outside of the building to not to not
bring the
the disease here now that's been right
as alan iverson said just
at practice we hadn't started traveling
yet but i do think some of the
technology that we use
here that may be different than other
places that
that can tell you on a day-to-day basis
you know how close you are and how much
time are you spending
in in the in the warning proximity
uh that allows you to then uh let's call
it do an after action review and say
maybe we
we ought to write split some people out
uh keep them a little bit farther apart
so that
if there is an unfortunate
uh outbreak within uh you know each
player
isn't at that point in a warning zone so
we're going to kind of take that
approach
uh early and and and see how it works
but we definitely have discussed it on a
week-to-week basis on
on what is the best measure to make sure
key positions if you i guess you'd call
it right preparing for
uh the most catastrophic if you can say
right losing a player for an nfl
football game is catastrophic
no no i understand that no no no no les
we're talking about
no you're talking about what and
understand and i appreciate you giving
that caveat
because we know what catastrophic in the
era of covet is and i i don't
i hope nobody is thinking that you would
ever use that cavalierly but for your
job
to put football players on the field and
we are you know in the
we're in the season and you're in the
construct of having to win football
games because that is what your job is
no having having basically jared goff
testing positive on a saturday
that would be um catastrophic certainly
if it's before an
nfc championship game you know what i'm
saying like that's the sort of thing
that
that i'm wondering how a general manager
can plan for
well it's interesting we did have a
mantra in the building right and
and and we're to that week we're right
we're going to keep score
and you know those scores are going to
be recorded and they're going to they're
going to show up in standings and and
right
and people like yourself right analyze
those scores
and standings throughout the season so
we've said
within the building right hey let's
remember the mantra
we're here to win games and this year
we'll add it
as safely as possible and and that's
always the case
because football is a dangerous sport
with the athletic performance but now
you actually have to add the asterisks
and do some things out of the box
because of the
the pandemic but rich you made the
biggest point ever because obviously
when i bored you to death
with my bullet points i think i got
through
six and the most important one was
all of that that i just said that uh you
are probably gonna cut out of your show
or what have you not making the house
all of those six better do one thing
better win games and uh so in our
formula right since
since 2017 we're fourth and win so
however you analyze
what you're doing and we know that you
can be biased in looking at it it does
need the equal
win so you make a good important point
there right we're getting to a point in
the season where
wins do matter definitely right and it
starts uh oh my gosh cowboys in the new
in the new building on on sunday night
that's gonna be
amazing uh enjoy that despite the fact
you know what's amazing there's a game
tonight right
that's right yeah yeah that's right we
have made it
sure y'all been talking about it a
little bit we might talk about a little
bit more
because the guys who met you you must be
like don't come at me for jalen ramsey
uh
uh contract numbers why don't you go
with that whole 500 million
10 10-year deal right i mean you want to
talk about
busting norms that's enormous but you
got to hang it to
uh to to lee steinberg and his group
right
if there was going to be someone to be
creative and go out of the box
you know it seems fitting that it would
it would not be
ironic it would be coincidental that it
was himself well i mean it's a platinum
box now and by the way i'm just
wondering do you have a
uh is lee holding you up in a
negotiation are you using this show to
butter him up a little bit is that what
you just did uh you know what uh
uh do not have probably if i only had
one player uh since
you know what i should say this but no
negotiations yet
uh lee steinberg and his partner chris
cabot have daryl henderson so
there you go all right very good hey les
thanks for the time greatly appreciate
it i think uh
dumb boy my coordinated producer
executive producers put a put a
a little split screen together you with
thomas dimitrov right there
um hair on hair who takes this one down
les
seriously well i think i think just
let's call it all things considered
you know thomas and maybe it's the socks
he wears
you know i mean you know what i mean
that hair but he's great
more than i have yes but uh he's
definitely
done that but i think total package
thomas
you know thomas williams probably took
expensive accessories to get there
yeah i know you you just you just wake
up looking like that i'm sure
um thomas he definitely leads nfl gm's
in the lava lamp department i think
if i had to guess no doubt
and and and we all know thomas now as
successful gm that the the
we everyone should have got a chance to
know thomas when
he was living in in boulder colorado
absolutely these are guys
oh gee it's uh on behalf of thomas uh
we're out of time
um thanks for the time last enjoy the
season we'll
win the show what are really good you
gotta go to your advertising you gotta
pay the bills
we do and uh and i appreciate the time
you take care of yourself less
all right see you thank you that's
lesney
is he buttoned up on the numbers what do
you think and the bullet points the
numbers and knowing what they are
since this time to that time and where
this guy can play hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here